A reflection acting on
the coordinate plane
takes point G to
point H and point
S to point T. What is
the line of reflection?
So the line of
reflection is going
to look something like that.
And it's going to go through
the midpoints of H and G,
which is going to be
someplace over there,
and the midpoint
of S and T, which
is going to be some
place over there.
And I'm drawing it
very imprecisely.
And the way we
think about it, when
we take the reflection of
G over this line you would
drop a perpendicular and
then go the same distance
on the other side to get
the point H. Similarly--
I can never say
that word-- if we
were to take the reflection
of S around that line
we would drop a perpendicular
to that midpoint
and then keep going
the same distance to T.
So let's think about
what these midpoints are,
and actually I'll clear this
right now just so that I can
draw it a little
bit more precisely.
So let's clear that.
And so H is at the
point 2, negative 2.
G is at the point negative
2 comma negative 6.
So what's the midpoint?
Well, the midpoint
is going to be
the midpoint of
the x-coordinates.
2 plus negative 2
is 0, over 2 is 0.
So the x-coordinate
is going to be 0.
The y-coordinate, the average
of negative 2 and negative 6
is negative 4.
So our midpoint is going
to be right over here.
It's the point 0, negative 4.
Now let's think about the
midpoint of these two points.
S is at the point 1.5 comma 5.5.
And T is at the point negative
9.5 comma negative 5.5.
So the midpoint is going to be
1.5 plus negative 9.5 over 2.
That's the x-coordinate.
I just took the average of
these two x-coordinates.
And the y-coordinate is going
to be 5.5 plus negative 5.5
over 2.
So what is this?
This is 1.5 plus negative
9.5 is negative 8 over 2.
So that is negative 4 comma 0.
So their midpoint is at the
point negative 4 comma 0.
So that point right over there.
Let me just write this.
This is negative 4 comma 0.
So the line of
reflection is going
to be the line that goes
through both of these points.
And we can write it in the
traditional slope intercept
form, y is equal to mx plus b.
So let's figure out its slope.
Let's figure out the slope
between these two points,
to go from negative 4
comma 0 to 0, negative 4.
Well, to go between those
two points, our change in y--
Actually, let me do this
in a different color
just to ease the monotony.
So our change in y over
here is negative 4.
As we go from this point
to that point we go 4 down,
and our change in x is
equal to positive 4.
So m, which is our change
in y over change in x,
we see that when we
increased our x by 4,
our y went down by 4, so
the slope is negative 1.
And now let's think about
what the y-intercept is.
Well we already know that.
When x is equal to
0, y is equal to b.
But we see over here
that this point is there.
So when x is equal to
0, y is negative 4.
So this is negative 4.
So the equation of
our line of reflection
is y is equal to negative
1x, or I could just
write negative x minus 4.
That's our line of reflection.
Now they ask us what
are the coordinates
of the image of point
negative 2 comma negative 2
under this reflection?
So the point negative
2 comma negative 2,
that's this point
right over here.
That sits on the
line of reflection.
When x is equal to negative
2, negative negative 2
is positive 2, minus
4 is negative 2.
This sits on this
line of reflection.
So the coordinates of
the image of this point
under the reflection,
well it's just
going to map back to itself.
It's going to be negative
2 comma negative 2.
Anything that's on the line of
reflection, when you reflect it
across that line, since
it sits on that line,
it's just going to
map back to itself.